thank you
martial arts one of anime's most
satisfying and grounded types of combat
we've seen time and time again that
despite the lack of magic spams or
anything of that nature a good old
hand-to-hand fight scene will always
reign supreme when it comes to
showcasing skill and Mastery which makes
it the perfect vessel for some badass
flexing while adding magic and the likes
to it only elevates the martial arts
element so I present to you the best
martial arts Flexes in anime let's get
right to it if we're talking about
flexing then this fight scene definitely
Takes the Cake
a one-sided beat down that gave shunsui
zero chance to even retaliate you
couldn't even call this a fight at this
point due to the Gap in both strength
and skill amongst the two competitors
the fight started with shunsui charging
towards his imminent defeat seemingly
filled with Vigor and energy and opening
with a strong left punch which Barky
easily Dodges the events that follow
this was nothing short of a flex as
Barky strikes shunsu's in with perfect
accuracy rambling his brain like a
pinball game followed by a left uppercut
as if the first punch wasn't enough to
knock him out in the first place and
that's not all as this final strike was
definitely the last nail in the coffin
as Barky hits him Square in the jaw with
a powerful roundhouse kick sending him
as the narrator would put it in a world
far far away the fight ended with Bucky
not breaking a single sweat and with his
opponent unconscious on the floor if
that's not called flexing then I don't
know what it is
[Music]
next up on this list we have one of the
most satisfying beat downs in the series
takamura vs Hawks
the match started with Hawks gaining the
upper hand as takamura was struggling to
keep up with hawks's unorthodox way of
boxing even losing Consciousness for a
bit only barely waking up again to dodge
a devastating blow that was headed his
way the match went on with Hawks at an
advantage but it all changed when
takamura lost Consciousness he recorded
memories of what happened before the
match which made him snap and retaliated
with a flurry of punches fueled by his
anger of hawks the match was then
concluded on round eight as takamura's
momentum from the previous round just
kept on going eventually resulting in a
standing count and Hawks losing the
ability to keep on going but the flex
didn't end there seeing as takamura
literally beat this guy so hard he later
developed PTSD breaking down just with
the slight mention of takamura's name
just cares to show how much of a bee
stuck Amura really is
thank you
this one here is surely one of the most
unexpected fights in the series
seeing as rihito a pre-established
character in the series mind you went up
against gensei a character that the
viewers don't even know much of seeing
as this was his debut in the anime the
match was basically a lecture for rihito
seeing as gensey could have easily taken
him out of the match if he took him
seriously Landing several lethal blows
and exclaiming how he could have killed
him in those moments was a flex in and
of itself but the fact that he's
practically schooling him what he's
doing here is what elevates this Flex
more pointing out his flaws not only in
skill but in his character the match was
basically over when gensey did a proper
fighting stance dodging rihito slashes
and Landing a devastating blow to his
chest and arm ending it all with a solid
punch to the face rihito was just out of
luck in this scenario seeing as he was
facing the final boss in the first match
gensey also didn't look down on the
mocked rihi though for his inadequacies
as he didn't mean to humiliate him in
the whole match flexing while being
humble and compassionate is something
that we don't really see much in anime
and this fight managed to do that
perfectly
Jordan
the most recent anime on this list we
have hell's Paradise with Gabi Maru the
hollow himself
the anime just started and we're already
blessed with the fight scene that's so
accurate to its source material which is
always a promising start the scene truly
highlighted Gabi maru's ferocity and
wild style of fighting as he rips and
bites his enemies as if he's wielding a
blade some are even decapitated which
are displayed in a gruesome manner in
the show he instilled fear not only in
his opponents but also to the onlookers
that were present at the scene and he
did all of this while his hands were
restrained making you wonder how deadly
this Shinobi would be if he were to
fight with any handicaps you should also
keep in mind he didn't use any Ninjutsu
in this fight his opponents weren't that
weak either seeing as they were one of
Japan's most horrid and Infamous
criminals which means they themselves
are also capable of violence but the
thing that separates them from Gabi Maru
is none other than skill and oh boy was
that displayed
it only feels right if we include some
classic anime in this list so next up we
have Fist of the North Star kenshiro vs
Hart
the next Flex victim we have is heart
one of the four Chief vassals of the
king organization a formidable opponent
that mostly negates blunt force-based
attacks due to his physique which makes
him a direct counter to most martial
arts techniques one might think that
kenshiro would have a relatively hard
time against his type of opponent well
you guessed wrong the fight opened with
kenshiro failing his first attempt in
killing this massive obstacle due to his
massive blubber with his hands stuck
heart delivered a massive counter-attack
which forced kenshiro onto the ground
after recovering from the attack
kenshiro Unleashed a flurry of attacks
and finished it off with a direct attack
in the now vulnerable stomach blowing up
his entire body in the process turning
him into Red Mist the flex that is his
partner Rey could have handled the
situation due to his attacks focusing
more on slicing as opposed to blunt
attacks but kenshiro just had to deny
his request and take care of it himself
all for the flex I suppose
[Music]
[Applause]
enjoyed the Beatdown that he received
from daiju Mikey makes his entrance in
the church with the usual Carefree
attitude that we love from him of course
foreign
managed to land the first hit on him
seemingly knocking Mikey out cold only
for him to stand back up and say that it
was punishment for himself implying that
he took the punch head on without the
intention of even blocking it in the
first place Mikey's cold State alone
shows how much he means business in this
moment and the following sequence of
events showed that as Mikey smashes
daiju on the floor with an attack that
we didn't even get to see due to its
immense speed and remember this was
after daiju got an extensive flashback
that shows his insane strength and Mikey
just dropped him within one frame and
here I thought flashbacks make you
stronger but Mikey wasn't even the only
one flexing in this scenario seeing as
draken just off-screened all the black
dragon members by himself might I had
the moment these two stepped in the
fight was already a wrap
huh
next up we have Naruto Rockley versus
Gara a fan favorite fight scene where
two competitors with highly different
fighting stars going toe-to-toe against
each other
broccoli specializes in taijutsu whereas
Gara focuses more on Ninjutsu two highly
different people not only in their
preferred fighting star but also in
their personality the one thing that
sets this fight apart is none other than
Rock Lee finally showing everyone the
fruits of his labor and hard work and of
course we must mention the iconic weight
removal scene an iconic Flex that shows
how much of a beast Rock Lee is in close
quarters combat which is shown in how
much he overpowered Gara after removing
his weights moving at such high speed
that he only appears like a blur to the
audience to a point that even Garner
couldn't keep up with him yeah he did
lose but it was only by a close margin
had it been anyone else Rockley would
have easily won but rockley's the men's
show of power is impressive enough on
its own after all opening five inner
gates is again in is something only
prodigies are capable of
next is this flight from hitori noshita
if we're talking about flexing and
martial arts then this scene deserves to
be in it no questions asked the
choreography mixed with the stellar and
fluid animation is so out of this world
you can hardly follow the moves that
these guys are pulling this was all made
possible due to the collaboration of
both Chinese and Japanese Studios an
insane opener for the series season 3
where we're straight up introduced to a
hype Chase slash fight scene which was
intense from start to finish and the
intensity only grows as the fight
progresses a definite Flex in my opinion
the fight then ends when he sends his
final opponent flying with a single
punch straight into a river a scene that
100 deserves to be on this list
we've finally reached the end and we
have the main antagonist in the Dark
Tournament none other than doguro one of
use case arch nemesis
foreign
the entire fight with yusuke was
basically himself always at a
disadvantage and whenever he manages to
one-up toguro he simply only increases
his power level and that cycle repeats a
total Monster not only in strength but
also appearance as he physically deforms
the more his output of power increases
which only makes him more menacing his
power output control is also a perfect
vessel in making him the ultimate this
isn't even my full strength
stereotypical anime character which does
make for a tense fight as he slowly
increases in power he leaves us to
wonder if yusuke could even beat such a
monster when dogaro finally deemed
yusuke worthy he unleashes a hundred
percent of his power which turned him
into a hulking mass of a monster which
is just a hundred percent muscle turning
even just the flick of his finger
equivalent to that of a normal punch a
total Menace that kept the audience and
participants on their toes his existence
in the tournament was a flex itself
showing the gray Gap in strength which
worked wonders in keeping up the
suspense and hype in the ark
and that's the end of the video with so
many characters mainly utilizing martial
arts this list was a blast to make and I
hope you enjoyed it don't forget to like
And subscribe and maybe give me your
thoughts in the comment section below
thank you so much for watching this
video